en el vídeo anterior echamos un vistazo
al mecanismo para la oxidación de
alcoholes en este vídeo
haremos ejemplos específicos para
diferentes tipos de alcoholes
comenzaremos con un alcohol primario
primero identificamos el carbono unido
al h como mi carbono alfa para que este
mecanismo funcione necesitamos al menos
un hidrógeno unido a nuestro carbono
alfa entonces si reaccionamos nuestro
alcohol primario con di cromato de sodio
ácido sulfúrico y agua a lo que llamamos
reactivo de iones
en este mecanismo vamos a oxidar a
nuestro carbono alfa y perder uno de
esos protones unido al carbono alfa lo
que nos daría un grupo funcional
aldehído incrementamos el número de
enlaces carbono oxígeno
perdemos un enlace carbono hidrógeno y
la dificultad está en aislar este
aldehído usualmente es muy difícil de
aislar y la oxidación continuará y
tendrás una segunda oxidación que
producirá ácidos carboxílicos como
producto final
entonces si hacemos reaccionar un
alcohol primario con el reactivo de
jones terminaremos teniendo un ácido
carboxílicos
veamos un ejemplo utilizaremos etanol
como nuestro alcohol primario
si hacemos reaccionar etanol con el
reactivo de jones
aquí el cromo en el cromato de sodio es
cromo 6 más que tiene un color
anaranjado
entonces cuando empiezas con la reacción
se va a ver un poco anaranjado debido al
cromo presente y cuando oxidamos nuestro
alcohol primario cuando oxidamos nuestro
etanol vamos a convertirlo en un ácido
carboxílicos no vamos a cambiar el
número de carbonos va a seguir habiendo
2 carbonos
así pero ahora vamos a cambiarlo a un
ácido
carboxílicos
por lo que el ácido acético va a ser
nuestro producto bien entonces pasamos
de este carbono teniendo un enlace a
oxígeno y lo oxidamos por lo que ahora
este carbono tiene tres enlaces a dos
átomos de oxígeno en ese proceso se
oxida moss ese carbono alfa vamos a
reducir el cromo el cromo va a pasar de
un estado de oxidación de 6 más y
eventualmente va a alcanzar un estado de
oxidación de 3 más como lo dijimos en el
vídeo anterior que tiene un color
verdoso lo que hace que sea muy sencillo
monitorear esta reacción solamente
viendo el cambio de color y esta es una
reacción muy muy rápida fue
originalmente utilizada para las pruebas
de aliento para determinar si había
etanol presente
muy bien ahora veamos qué ocurre si
quisiéramos detener la reacción en el
aldehído no queremos que la oxidación
continúe hasta el ácido carboxílicos
digamos que quisieras que se detuviera
en el aldehído
pues para hacer eso tendríamos que
utilizar un reactivo diferente entonces
vamos a ver cómo podemos detener la
reacción hasta después de la primera
oxidación si empezamos con un alcohol
primario vamos a volver a dibujar un
alcohol primario rápidamente así
y si quisiéramos oxidar lo solo una vez
de manera que obtuviéramos un aldehído
el mejor reactivo para ello
es conocido como cloro cromato de
pirineos o té
echemos un vistazo a la estructura del
reactivo psc rápidamente
entonces pirineo vamos a mostrar cómo es
es derivado de una piscina vamos a
dibujar esto así muy bien la piscina es
una base va a tomar un protón para
formar una carga positiva aquí y luego
tenemos un cr
y luego sé
y luego una carga negativa esta sería la
parte premio vamos a escribir pi
unión
y luego tenemos cloro
cromato del lado derecho voy a escribir
cloro cromato
y eso hace más fácil ver de dónde viene
él
entonces este es el reactivo de cc que
es un reactivo mucho más mucho más suave
que el reactivo de iones
va a oxidar el alcohol primario y se
detendrá en el aldehído entonces vamos a
hacer reaccionar el etanol nuevamente
esta vez usaremos psc en vez de jobs
y empezáramos con etanol y le añadiera
mos
cc aquí vamos terminaremos con un
aldehído y es un aldehído de 2 carbonos
bien podemos decir que esos 2 carbonos
siguen estando aquí y vamos a formar un
doble enlace y esta vez va a ser un
aldehído este es el canal o acetaldehído
que sería el resultado de esta reacción
de oxidación y eso sería todo en cuanto
a alcoholes primarios
veamos ahora la oxidación de alcoholes
secundarios comenzaremos con una
reacción general aquí entonces tenemos
un alcohol secundario tendría dos grupos
alquilo diferentes o pueden ser iguales
unidos a nuestro carbono alfa nuestro
carbono alfa está unido a un o h y
recuerden para que el mecanismo funcione
debe haber un hidrógeno unido a ese
carbono alfa entonces este es mi alcohol
secundario ahora para los alcoholes
secundarios solo puedes obtener un
producto
en el vídeo anterior vimos que cuando
oxidadas un alcohol secundario obtienes
una zona
así que para un alcohol secundario se
puede se puede utilizar jones
o puedes usar
y cualquiera de los dos reactivos oxidar
a al alcohol secundario a un acetona
veamos un ejemplo comenzaremos con un
alcohol secundario voy a dibujar un
anillo de benceno aquí
y unido a ese benceno habrá un alcohol
secundario presente entonces este es mi
alcohol secundario y si agregar a jones
o psc
jones
o
se hace de un y alcohol secundario
identifico mi carbono alfa es el que
está unido al h y puedo ver que hay un
hidrógeno unido a ese carbono alfa este
es un alcohol secundario entonces cuando
dibujo el producto voy a convertir ese
alcohol secundario en un acetona si
hiciera eso rápidamente voy a dibujar y
benceno aquí convertiría ese carbono
alfa en una se torna
este sería mi producto muy bien
veamos ahora un alcohol terciario si
tuviera un alcohol terciario como un
cerdo butanol así
y si quisiera oxidar ese alcohol
terciario con jones o psc como vimos en
el vídeo anterior no hay reacción porque
si encontrara el carbono alfa este
carbono de aquí no hay hidrógenos unidos
a ese carbono alfa y de nuevo vimos en
el mecanismo que eso era necesario algo
como el tercer butanol no podrá ser
oxidado de este modo eso resume la
oxidación de alcoholes